[Musica]
alzi la mano chi di voi almeno una volta
nella vita ha pensato di non farcela
ok ora alzi la mano chi almeno una volta
nella vita ha incontrato qualcuno che
gli ha detto che non ce l'avrebbe fatta
ok
immagino che vi sia capitato
innumerevoli volte di pensare di non
farcela e altrettante di incontrare
qualcuno che vi dicesse che voi non
foste in grado non siete i soli e io
devo dirvi che oggi sono qua per
raccontarvi che ogni volta in cui
l'avete pensato di stavate sbagliando
e successo anche a me da quando sono
bambino non mi sono mai sentita brava o
la più brava
ecco la più brava proprio no figuriamoci
magari svegliassi ma brava mica tanto
perché gli altri ai miei occhi anche
figlio non mi sono mai considerata così
male avevano sempre qualcosa più di me
più bravi più belli più intelligenti più
qualche cosa insomma e devo dirvi che il
peggio per la mia autostima è arrivato
quando ero in prima liceo
ricordo benissimo era passato neanche un
mese dall'inizio della scuola e il mio
professore d'italiano disse a mia madre
durante il primo colloquio
pensavo che dietro la raci fosse molto
poi ho capito che non c'era niente
avete capito dopo neanche dieci lezioni
d'italiano e io ci credevo
era il mio professore non era mica uno
stupido come potevo non crederci ma i
danni alla mia autostima non sono ancora
finiti
qualche anno dopo ero in quinta liceo il
ricordo che dopo il diploma mio padre mi
portò da un grafologo per l'orientamento
lui guardando la mia scrittura senza
pormi alcuna domanda mi fisso e mi disse
lara tuo padre mi ha detto che vuoi fare
la psicologa ecco devi sapere che non
tutti nascono per fare gli psicologi e
psicologi si nasce e non si diventa
e tu non puoi far la psicologa sei
troppo empatica ti porteresti a casa i
problemi di tutte le altre persone sai
che cosa saresti adatta a fare
critica all'editoria
ragazzi io non sapevo nemmeno che cosa
fosse critica l'editoria ma sapete che
cosa successe chi mi scrisse una facoltà
che mi portava proprio fare quel lavoro
a me sconosciuto
oggi però io non sono qui a raccontarvi
di me
oggi io sono qua a dimostrarvi perché io
su di me e voi su voi stessi vi
sbagliavate
vi dirò qualcosa di più
vi siete sbagliati
ogni volta in cui avete pensato di non
essere all'altezza
vi siete sbagliati
ogni volta in cui avete pensato di non
farcela
essere da meno
ogni volta in cui pensavate che quella
cosa non facesse per voi oppure quando
avete creduto alle persone che nel tempo
vi hanno definito vi sbagliavate
e come se vi sbagliavate perché devo
dirvi che quando poi ho iniziato a fare
ricerca e studi nel mio lavoro ho
compreso che non si trattava di bassa
autostima ma di qualche cosa di più che
a che fare con le nostre credenze perché
quando noi guardiamo il mondo non lo
vediamo così come in modo logico
razionale e coerente
quando noi guardiamo il mondo lo
costruiamo attraverso delle convinzioni
soggettive cioè e con i nostri occhi che
noi leggiamo le altre persone noi stessi
le situazioni e noi costruiamo queste
convinzioni soggettive a parte sire da
piccole esperienze all'interno della
nostra vita della nostra infanzia e poi
le estraiamo tutti gli altri eventi
della nostra vita in modo del tutto
illogico e irrazionale soggettivo
potremmo addirittura dire che esistono
tanti mondi quante menti
sembra pazzesco ma è così
e queste credenze hanno un nome si
chiamano distorsioni cognitive
devo dirvi che in realtà hanno anche
qualche cosa di funzionale non è mica
per niente che le mettiamo in campo ci
aiutano di fronte alla molteplicità di
informazioni
a prendere delle decisioni
ma diventano completamente disfunzionali
quando li mettiamo in campo in modo
esteso rigido senza nemmeno esserne ne
serve consapevoli o rendersene conto
e nessuno di noi ne sente nessuno di voi
qua è immune a mettere in campo
distorsioni cognitive per raccontarvelo
vi faccio qualche esempio
mettiamo in campo false credenze quando
i per generalizziamo partiamo da dati
elias traiamo senza alcun tipo di
ragione ad altri che magari
semplicemente un po ci assomigliano non
ho passato un esame non lo passerò mai è
accaduto stavolta a mi accadrà sempre
oppure quando catastrofi siamo mi ha
lasciato il mio ragazzo non troverò mai
più nessuno come lui o resterò solo per
sempre oppure ancora il cosiddetto
pensiero dicotomico polarizzato bianco e
nero nessuno mi capisce o sono tutti
meravigliosi
o ancora quando ci confrontiamo con le
altre persone e ci sentiamo sempre da
meno rispetto a loro
o quando mettiamo in campo la lettura
del pensiero questa tutte ce l'abbiamo
c'è qualcuno che ci sta guardando e
pensiamo a mi sta guardando male c'è
lassù con me guarda come mi sta
guardando
senza dati oggettivi a tra cui
attribuiamo giudizi e sentimenti agli
altri oppure facciamo delle pi per per
finalizzazioni cioè senza l'avallo di
dati oggettivi ci diciamo noi stessi
sono proprio uno stupido
e poi mettiamo in campo quello che è il
locus of control quando viaggiamo locus
of control e esterno quando le cose
vanno bene o qualcosa ha funzionato
allora non è stato grazie a me è stato
grazie alla fortuna il caso invece
quando le cose vanno male le attribuiamo
noi stessi con un locus of control
interno sono io che ho fallito non è
stato il caso il destino
e devo dirvi che
dobbiamo fare attenzione perché ognuna
di queste credenze quando noi pensiamo
che siano vere
udite udite le rendiamo noi reali si
realizzano veramente e questa è la
profezia che si autoavvera
un meccanismo attraverso il quale
pensiamo che qualche cosa sia vero
agiamo come se fosse tale e udite udite
avviene vi faccio qualche esempio
pensate una persona che pensa di non
essere interessante teme il rifiuto da
parte delle altre persone all'ora
all'interno di situazioni sociali
cercherà di ritrarsi un po di non farsi
tanto vedere da un punto di vista
sociale in mezzo agli altri magari
manderà avanti un po le amiche sapete
che cosa succederà di conseguenza che le
altre persone non avvicineranno faranno
fatica a
interessarsi a lei perché non sarà
visibile e allora attraverso un
meccanismo con cui voleva allontanare il
rifiuto degli altri giunge esattamente a
confermarlo
e sapete qual è il punto che quando noi
mettiamo in campo queste credenze senza
sforzo in modo improvviso ci sembrano
vere e quando qualcosa ci sembra vero
difficilmente lo mettiamo in discussione
dovete sapere che quando noi mettiamo in
campo queste credenze non soltanto
arriviamo ad agire profezie che si auto
realizzano ma quello che ci accade e che
proviamo anche delle emozioni
estremamente negative
qualcuno di noi può provare tristezza
senso d'inadeguatezza
vergogna angoscia magari anche un po
d'ansia quella non ce la facciamo mai
mancare
e io su di me mi sbagliavo
io oggi sono una psicologa e sono qua
insieme a voi oggi nel mio lavoro
ricevo riconoscimenti che mai avrei
pensato di ricevere in una vita intera
quando ho scelto di fare il mio lavoro
ho voluto che l'intento che lo guidasse
fosse vedere all'interno delle persone
non deficit patologie o difficoltà con
l'intento di etichettare bensì ho scelto
di vedere dentro le persone risorse
qualità punti di forza con la volontà di
far fiorire
e questo quello che cerco di fare
quotidianamente nel mio lavoro vedere
distese di prati fioriti là dove le
persone si riconoscono soltanto deserti
aridi
guidarli a sapersi guardare a sapersi
vedere al di là delle solite distorsioni
cognitive che siamo soliti crearci e
creare e
il punto è questo che anche voi ognuno
di voi che siete qua oggi avete punti di
forza qualità e risorse ma non le sapete
vedere anche tu li hai anche tu
il punto è che non siamo in grado di
guardarli di vederci
e vi dirò qualcosa in più ancora che la
ricerca ha dimostrato che chi arriva
nella vita non è chi ha grandi talenti
ci arriva nella vita è chi crede di
poter cambiare e crescere migliorare e
allora anche tu lo puoi fare
inizia a vedere inizia a vederti parti
da qua
ogni volta che trovi in te un difetto
cerca in the una risorsa
ogni volta che leggi una prospettiva va
in cerca di un'alternativa da minaccia a
opportunità ogni volta in cui vedi una
persona vicino a te negativa va in cerca
di chi ti supporta e ci è vicino
e allora quando inizierai a saperti
vedere al di là delle tue credenze e
delle definizioni delle altre persone
tiri scoprirai per chi sei con le tue
risorse e ti accorgerai che se anche le
cose sono così come sono
tu puoi cambiarle come puoi fare
cambiando prospettiva perché ti renderai
conto che se tu puoi cambiare
prospettiva puoi cambiare la tua vita e
le cose possono essere così come sono ma
tu vederla in modo diverso e vedere
anche te stesso in modo differente e
allora parti ora perché questo potere ce
l'hai e dentro di te stasera quando
tornerai a casa e ti troverai davanti
allo specchio
fermati e guardati
accenna un sorriso
e si gentile con te stesso per donandoti
per tutte le volte in cui ti sei
trattato male hai di fronte a te la
persona più importante dalla tua vita
soffermati su di lei si pronto a
scoprire chi sei e a stupirti di tutto
quello che hai
[Applauso]